I got family out here I got my
girlfriend so we're gonna be spending a
lot of time with with my family and my
girlfriend it's only October but Samus
Gauri is already thinking about the
holidays with his love Britney Spears et
chatted with the actor at WWE's at
twentieth anniversary celebration where
he also reacted to Britney's recent
Instagram post about taking time off
work to stop and reflect about what she
really wants to do that's a great
message you know the same goes with me
as always you know I took some time away
from everything on myself you know you
got to do that stuff in order to stay on
top of your career stay on top of your
life so you're gonna have more to offer
to your family members and the people
that you love the 25 year old is
actually focused on work right now we're
working on some TV shows and movies
going on big auditions so we're gonna be
doing that great things with movie
industry apparently he's got something
with Jamie Foxx in the works it was a
friendly project that we did I can't
tell you anything yet but you know keep
your eye out and hopefully it's
something great you know he's a cool guy
obviously is that you can he can sing he
can act he can do anything it's one of
the most talented guys out there and
he's so humble and next on Sam's Coast
our bucket list Dwayne the rock Johnson
who returned to the WWE for the big
night Rock is you know obviously a great
inspiration for everyone but to me you
know he came into wrestling you know he
overcame so much to go into the acting
industry you know as far as the way he
looked people said that you know he
wasn't able to do every role but now
he's doing you know every goal that
there is and he's one of the biggest
actors so I admire that career
[Music]